you know I'm a massive fan of Silicon
Valley I love your show - oh what a
prick it's cute what you do here you
like this
yeah we've just been doing it a little
while we might keep doing it yeah okay
you're an awful person huh
I know you guys in the cast
I've come to interview all of you I
think and you're all lovely people you
probably heard about your cast mate
Kumail he was supposed to be on our show
he missed his appearance through no
fault of his own he just couldn't make
it and so I brought my assistant sona
out and and since then I've been
thinking like okay is this gonna be like
a Silicon Valley cast problem you know
where I book one of you guys and then
you don't show at the last second is
this something that's gonna is this
something it's a danger of happening I
mean in all sincerity I would never do
that to you
Conan ever and to be honest Kumail was
mortified he was really upset I'm just
kidding he was like thank God I don't
have to do that show he's like god what
what I've just really dodged a bullet
yeah you know I love your doing this but
you're wearing a microphone you're
saying it into your microphone Joe chat
anybody yeah yeah but I've murdered and
I was like Kumail he's like a comedy
icon you should do a show he's like I
got two words suck it like like
old-school like no ww8 a fan of Shawn
Michaels yeah man that is I didn't know
he was that kind of guy yeah well now
he's now he's in Marvel Star so it's got
big muscles now do the math pal yeah
yeah ever heard of this that's what he's
doing
yeah you'll see he'll say huh easy in a
Marvel nice in a Marvel movie is one of
the Immortals with Angelina Jolie and
who knows who knows who else okay I
don't read isn't he I don't read the
trades well I know what's happening he's
in what he's in London England dear old
dear old merry old England across the
pond as they say getting ripped no no
that was necessary you you just say he's
in England was a chip chap in a chip
shop yeah the little fish and chips Izzy
yeah Dutch touch the u-boats on the
right over hanging on by a predator yeah
yeah he's he's working out and having
controlled meals and staying fit okay
and got abs abs for days this boy yeah
yeah he sent me like a mirror like
selfie shot and he's like he's like do I
look good now right really he did send
you one yeah we send each other foot
okay we're do tip for debt yeah you know
you guys I do think you have a you seem
like you're friends you do good that
shows that the acting is working yeah
most of us can't stand each other but no
no yeah we're all quite well like for
example we had Zack woods on the other
day I love that guy what's that what cat
piss I know that taste anywhere
yeah you know how hard it is to get a
good took a six days if you think of
need everywhere but the cup in a while
and if you think about how much a cat
pees that's a tremendous amount of
catfish to fill a mug well six different
times you got yeah I suppose I shouldn't
complain yeah rare after all yeah we had
to microwave it to keep it warm
well yeah as I said about 40 minutes ago
we had your friends that before he went
down cat piss alley you can't be comedy
gold I'm giving you hits out of the park
now there's a sports fan I'm giving you
hits out of the park I tell you I've
been paying attention till I heard cat
piss sometimes wanders away
no we I know that you guys are good
friends and I I was told that you do
this impression of a fan of Zach woods
using is this on the instagram what's
this snapchat oh yeah yeah well it's
weird uh you know I'll post something on
Instagram if I have Zach woods in it the
amount of not only fandom to be like oh
I wish he had a social media account I
wish I could see him more it's it's
typically sexually-charged like he has
there is a lust for mr. woods I'm
telling ya it out it is palpable and so
it heard that by the way yeah I've heard
that he's ladies go nuts for I mean way
to the same in person yeah yeah
a tremendous sexual energy that yeah but
that was a response you know I'd do all
these dumb Internet videos with filters
and stuff that's like me absorbing that
and here's you being a fan
[Applause]
I'll tell you she that's an intense fan
right she needs a shave yeah she needs
shaving a therapist